we've worked out the force acting along
the normal okay
that's good we know it's going in this
way okay but conversely in just the same
way that if you start with a projectile
right
like this right and then you're like oh
what's happening over here and you just
use trig it's all fine okay a natural
question to ask you is well what's
happening over here to the perpendicular
axis now what would you call this is the
normal axis that i've got in green what
would you call the other axis
that's perpendicular to that it's the
tangential axis okay now we're going to
draw this again because this diagram is
going to get so busy i recommend i've
seen textbooks they try and jam it into
one i'm going to ask you to draw this
diagram again but instead of having the
normal axis in here i want to compare it
to this tangential axis and we'll find
something really interesting
now it's worth pointing out even though
i'm focusing on this guy the tangential
axis
i still need
and maybe you want to put this in like
dots or something like that i still need
the normal axis in there because my
angle my angular displacement kind of
depends on the normal that's where it's
measured from okay so just in light dots
i'm going to put in
let's go to the center okay
i've got my angular displacement theta
in there right now think about the
triangles we drew over here i drew these
triangles because i was trying to match
up the horizontal and vertical bits to
the normal but this time i'm trying to
match up the horizontal and vertical
bits to the
tangent so i'm going to get a different
pair of triangles do you see that
different pair of triangles here's the
pair of triangles i'm going to get
but the horizontal bit that's a bad x
for the horizontal b i'm going to come
down this way to the tangential axis
make sense
and then for the vertical bit i'm going
to come down this way
again to the tangential axis
and now i need to work out with tree
what's going on in here okay here's my
angle theta so tell me where can i find
theta in this diagram
how would you like to describe it to me
next
okay so the theta
the first place i'm going to see it just
like i did before is just with
corresponding angles this is the x-axis
this is the x force so therefore by
corresponding angles i see theta in
there does that make sense
so that makes this the complement of
theta which means times u minus theta
which means theta's up in this corner
does that make sense
theta okay so now can you tell me again
by trig and thinking about the um
the right ratios and which sides you're
interested in that's f of x and that's
the side i'm interested in what ratio
means this side and that side
look carefully
it's gonna be sine right here's your
theta that's opposite
and that's the hypotenuse okay so if you
go ahead you can redraw again the same
diagrams but i'm going to save you a bit
of time
this here which is i'm going to call
this t for tangential part from x that's
going to be i believe f x sine
theta
that bit because sine theta will be
opposite on hypotenuse
and in the same way have a look over
here okay where's theta where's theta
tell me what theta is
if this is theta
this must be the complement of theta
right because right angles and then
you've got another right angle so that
makes this back to theta does that make
sense theta right there so now i'm
trying to connect this side here which
is adjacent to theta with this guy here
which is the hypotenuse f y right so you
can see before adjacent hypotenuse
it's cos
so this part here
t y
is going to be f of y cos theta
so far so good
so i'm basically rehearsing this but
because we um drew the diagonals before
i'm sort of going through it a little
quicker
okay now the wonderful thing about this
is have a look at these guys right can
you see they're both heading in the same
direction but things that's why i added
them right i added them but look at
these guys
they're necessarily heading in opposite
directions so therefore when i was
working out the force of the normal
capital m
the force of the normal i added but when
i'm working the working out the force
along the tangential axis
i have to
subtract one from the other does that
make sense so i'm going to say well
that's that's looking like it's in the
positive direction actually doesn't
really matter as you'll see in a second
so i'm going to say f of
uh
yep actually hold on which way did i
write it i'm gonna write this one first
okay there's that one and i'm going to
subtract it from
this one okay can you see they're facing
opposite directions so that's why i
subtract how do you know
just have a look at the directions that
my arrows are facing in i've looked at
the directions that my arrows are facing
in with respect to this tangent
okay
it doesn't matter all that much as you
will see in a second just watch uh what
is f of y cos theta well this is f of y
over here right so when i multiply that
guy by cos theta it looks to me like
it'll be minus m r omega squared
sine theta sine theta cos theta
okay then i have to subtract
and when you multiply that guy by sine
theta you're going to get minus m r
omega squared cos theta because they
decide they are
hold on the seconds
uh
same same same
same same
it's zero
force along the normal
headed towards the center
proportional to alter these things
cool
also in the tangent
zero
what does that mean it's a force on the
tangent being zero
because there's no acceleration
huh
so think about this right
the reason i ask you to reorient these
diagrams is so that you can think in
terms of what's happening along here
versus what's happening along here okay
now tell me what happens if you're
experiencing a force of zero what would
that mean to you
you are either now now now the newton's
first law is in play right you are
either stationary because you've all
seen zero and it's not changing or
you're moving in
constant
straight line motion concentrate that
motion but hold on didn't we just say
it's constantly changing direction right
so how come this is constantly not
changing direction
wait hold on wait no
because the tangent is changing all
right so the tangential axis it keeps on
moving right so therefore
what this means is right you're
experiencing inertia here so we call
this we said this in the very first
lesson and i said be patient right we
call this an inertial frame of reference
right
because if you picture yourself
right
sitting here okay like what is what was
that person on the edge doing that
person on the edge what they were
experiencing is they're just running
forwards
with relation to this tangent the
tangent keeps changing but you are
always running forwards does that make
sense
so therefore for uniform circular motion
you've got this
which is um just meaning you're going
the same speed all the way around and
then you've got this which is holding
you and making you move in a circle
rather than flying off like the discus
did does that make sense
okay
so huge ideas now let me just come back
and remember i said for homework right
when we went through this whole process
to work out uh
these guys
when we went through this whole process
we could regard omega as a constant why
could we do that again tell me why
uniform circular motion uniform section
of motion but not all circular motion is
uniform so my homework for you
you can do it now if you like
is if omega is in fact a function and
not just a constant
this step will be the same do you notice
this set will be the same right this has
no omegas in it you have to bring omega
in no big deal so all of this
is fine
but our next step will be very different
what's going to happen in our next step
to get to acceleration
okay
obviously i had to use chain rule i'm
going to have to do that but in addition
to that this is not just a constant a
constant and a function this is going to
be a function
times another function
so we're going to have to do product
rule now you can see why i didn't start
with that example some textbooks start
with non-cert uniform secular motion i'm
like are you nuts right yeah that's
right i think it's so much easier to
think about it just as a constant now
that you've gone through this and see
all the way we did it in a simple
version when this is not changing
i do want you to go through the result
you get at the end is not that
complicated but i want you to go through
having done you'll need product tool
here
okay
so
we've got um just under 20 minutes to go
what i'd like you to do is to open up
your laptops if you haven't already i
image emailed you out um remember before
i gave you 7.17.2 so i have now given
you 7.3 through to the end of the
chapter um
i'd like you to either give the first
two questions a go give the first two
questions again i'm pretty sure they're
uniform circular motion so you don't
need to do this just yet um or
alternatively you can have a go at this
now while it's still fresh in your mind
okay to try and rehearse this whole
thing treating omega is a function
i am
i spend most of my days
trying not to imagine resistant
circulation
um now one last thing before i relax one
last thing before i um
one last thing before i get you all
started remember i said to you oh it's
like two dimensions again look two
dimensions x and y's obviously but
actually it's sort of two and a half
dimensions so here's a simple example um
yeah okay um
picture a table picture a table okay and
then picture like um the center of the
string of a string here and then there's
an object which um through some
mysterious like inanimate force okay is
moving in uniform circular motion around
this okay now this is a very simple
question so you can see all the motion
is happening in two dimensions yeah all
the motions happening in two dimensions
but in order to understand mass mass
matters right um that matters uh you're
on a table
you're on a table
so therefore in what direction
is the mass
force acting
and the answer is it's acting through
the table right we call it weight right
wait um of course because you've got a
force acting downwards right have a look
at all these objects that are on the
table on which a weight force is acting
but they're not moving
why aren't they moving
because there's a reaction force so
here's his um weight gravity right not
to be confused with omega then you've
got this reaction force up here which is
acting
in a direction perpendicular to your
surface does that make sense and so
that's why these two balance each other
out and up and down no motion is
happening so it's 3d
uh this dimension up here you're not
worrying about any motion in that
dimension okay but your diagram will
include it that's why it's two that's
why it's two and a half okay so that
third dimension that's third spatial
dimension i'm not worried about any
change there so that's why i had to
account for it but then once i've dealt
with it i don't worry about it